et on continue sur cette su weekend avec
notre invité mon invité CIV bonjour
bonjour c'est l'automne là il fait froid
ah c'est alors vous allez nous
réchauffer parce que franchement il fait
pas beau du tout et on va on se rend du
côté de Rambouillet et de la vallée de
chevose avec vous alors c'est c'est le
moment de goûter les spécialités du
terroir les spécialités culinaire de de
se régaler en ces moments de de froid
effectivement à R est c'est la période
de gastronomie d'automne gastronomie
d'automne c'est donc jusqu'au 18
novembre donc on a encore quelques jours
pour en profiter c'est le moment de
redécouvrir les les produits d'automne
de la forêt les châignes les
champignons les les les gibiers aussi et
puis donc des restaurateurs se sont
associés à cette idée de la mairie de
Rambouillet et propose des menus du
terroir à cette occasion et puis
également ça nous permettra de
redécouvrir les produit typique de
Rambouillet comme la fesane c'est-à-dire
une terine de faisant la feuille
d'automne qui est un gâteau au chocolat
et puis des différents fromages de de
Rambouillet il y a même un jeu concours
qui est organisé et on peut gagner
l'occasion de ce jeu concours un dîner
pour deux personnes dans un restaurant
de Rouillet alors si on veut pas dîner
mais qu'on veut juste un panier gourmand
on peut aller à la Bergerie Nationale et
oui à la Bergerie nationale c'est B
c'est bons produits c'est le Paris
fermier donc c'est un grand marché
fermier en fait où vous pouvez découvrir
une centaine de producteurs de toute la
France qui vous proposent leurs produits
que l'on peut déguster puis acheter si
on le souhaite et puis on peut découvrir
aussi la façon dont on on on fait les
les produits
laitiers don la façon dont on élève les
poules les œufs bio comment comment tout
ça se passe et puis aussi la traite des
chèvres donc ça c'est c'est assez
amusant et puis il y a des des petites
promenades en calèche et puis des
promenades en sulky avec des ânes donc
tout ça est très original et ça permet
d'occuper ce weekend euh à l'extérieur
même s'il fait froid on se réchauffe en
mangeant et en dégustant les B 9 au 11
novembre une fois qu'on aura bien mangé
on va chanter c'est ça avec chance
autonne ah oui voilà toujours à rouiller
si on a bu en plus et c'est plus facile
pas consommer avec modération ah bah
bien sûr mais il y en a qui supportent
pas ça les fait chanter donc chansutonne
ça existe depuis 8 ans maintenant c'est
une découverte de la chanson française
avec des ateliers musicaux et des des
petits concert dans dans les
appartements on peut se faire un petit
concert chez soi et il y a un artiste
qui qui propose ses services qui
s'appelle Thomas Pitiot qui vous propose
de venir chez vous faire un petit
concert intimiste et puis il y aura
aussi ça c'est sympa tét pour un concert
gratuit et puis Chloé Lacamp Paris Combo
donc plein d'artistes qui qui sont là
pour retrouver un peu les les vraies
valeurs de la chanson française jazz
latino rock toutes sortes m zigan toutes
sortes de de musique alors on reste à
Rambouillet donc on chante on mange mais
il faut venir jusqu'à Rambouillet et
voilà si on prend pas la voiture on peut
prendre le train alors si on vient en
train à Rambouillet qu'on passe son
petit
weekend au milieu de de la forêt ou à
côté du château dans un hôtel et bien
l'Office de Tourisme vous rembourse
votre billet de train ça sera l'occasion
de découvrir effectivement les produits
gastronomiques de faire des randonnées à
vélo dans la ville ou bien aussi de de
participer à des rallyies dans la ville
alors ça c'est jusqu'au 16 décembre
décemb
Absolum on va on change de de coin on va
aller à la maison de Elsa Triolet et
Louis Aragon pour une exposition au du
qui s'intitule 56 rue de varen puisque
c'est c'est une reprise de l'appartement
parisien des triolis Aragon puisque leur
maison
se le moulin je chercher le le moulin en
fait était leur résidence secondaire et
il est donc à saint-arnou en Yveline
cette exposition
a lieu jusqu'au 30 novembre et elle
retrace effectivement dans le la
résidence secondaire qui est le moulin
l'appartement qui était le 56 rue de
varen avec des cartes postales avec des
lettres avec des des objets tout à fait
hétéroclyit qui sont punaisés qui sont
un petit peu mis dans une sorte de de
entre guillemets de cafarnaom et on
retrouve l'environnement de de d'Aragon
qui est quand même parti il y a des déjà
30 ans maintenant donc c'est un moyen de
se retransposer dans son univers c'est
univers de d'un grand écrivain
surréaliste donc c'est découvrir à la
maison Elsa Triolet Aragon c'est très
joli en plus un petit un petit bijou ce
moulin à saint-arnou on va à brotuil on
va jongler on va prendre les arts du
cirque les arts du cirque ça vite au
chil voilà et ça c'est jusqu'au 15
novembre donc vous avez les jongleurs
les acrobates les clown les petits
grands papiers qui vont animer ce
château de Breteuil
historique les les salles du Château Les
boiserie tout ça animé par par tout ce
qui a trait au cirque et puis faut
surtout pas oublier que il y a quand
même les comptes qui restent toujours
actif le dimanche on a trois comptes de
pro qui sont racontés par une compteuse
dans les dans les salons du château donc
surtout en profiter parce que quand il
fait froid c'est c'est bien d'écouter
des compes donc les les du CIRC jusqu'au
15 novembre voilà
pour y aller euh et puis des petites
choses à ne pas manquer oui alors Gour
les weekend gourmand encore une fois
beaucoup à chaque fois vous venez vous
nous on dirait que je pense qu'à ça j'
raison oui c'est le weekend gourmand en
dans la plaine de Versailles et c'est
dans le village de chavenet alors ça
c'est une une initiative qui est
complètement innovante ce sont les
habitants de chavenet qui invitent des
chefs des pâtissiers des zologues à
venir chez eux faire des préparations
quand ils ont une grande cuisine bien
sûr faire des préparations culinaires à
base de produits locaux des produits du
terroir de la plaine de Versailles euh
cette cette expérience c'est le 17 et le
18 novembre prochain et euh donc elle
est clôturée par un un goutté gourmand
avec à la base donc les produits du
terroir locaux et puis on s l'occasion
d'échanger ses
recettes son expérience un peu surt sur
toutes ces et préparations alors autre
activité que vous nous proposez c'est
jusqu'au 15 novembre aussi il faut se
dépêcher c'est la visite du château de
Dampierre Dierre alors magnifique
château privé du duc de luine qui est
donc à
dpierre et ce magnifique château privé
il a aussi un un parc et c'est aussi ça
qu'on vous qu'on propose de de découvrir
c'est un parc qui est dessiné par Le
Nôtre ça fait partie des magnifiques
parcs de Le Nôtre dont on va fêter
l'année prochaine l'anniversaire euh le
tricentenaire de la naissance et donc
dans ce parc il y a des parcours d'eau
qui sont extraordinaires et qui révèlent
vraiment la nature avec les magnifiqu
couleurs que l'on peut découvrir en
cette période d'automne et une dernière
proposition c'est le parc de toirie oui
pour les insectes alors le le parc de
toirie d'res animx oui oui oui mais ça
c'est quelque chose qui est très
innovant hein parce que le parc de toiri
a innové cette arche des petites bêtes
il y a il y a seulement quelques mois
donc ça si on l'a pas vu il faut
vraiment allez le découvrir c'est les
derni weend je suis il y a pas très
longtemps et ah non mais c'est c'est
très très bien alors l'âge des petites
bêtes c'est c'est quelque chose de de
très écologique puisque c'est un
vaisseau en bois tout est naturel les
propriétaires du du château Toir
préservent énormément l'environnement et
c'est dans ce cadre là qu'ils ont fait
c'est espèce d'arche de Noé en fin de
compte qui est en bois avec une partie
immergée où on peut découvrir grâce aux
soigneurs qui font qui vous font
découvrir leur vie euh des animaux qui
sont souvent mais connu enfin ou mal
connu que sont les Migal les wistity les
Gren et je conseille d'ailleurs un très
joli canapé oui je sais pas si vous avez
été vous avez ét visé large petit il y a
un canapé qui est qui est très joli qui
est très stylé on s'assoit dessus je ne
dis rien
ou a destites surpris il faut rien dire
mais c'est c'est surprenant ça fait peur
en tout c'est V VO il y a même des
caméléons enfin il y a toutes Ste de
choses et c'est les derniers weekends où
on peut on peut les visiter puisque
pendant la période hivernal Toir va
fermer ses portes donc ça va être c'est
maintenant ou après il faut attendre le
printemps donc le momentci merci
beaucoup C êt venu nous présenter toutes
ces idées de sorties dans le département
notamment beaucoup dans la région de de
Rambouillet mais tout autour aussi de de
Saint-Quentin merci beaucoup d'être
d'être venu